there's this saying that money can't buy
you class think you already know where
this is going there's been no person who
better embodies money can't buy you
class than Donald Trump and he decided
once again to pull this stunt where he
invites a college sports team to the
White House after a big win and he
serves them fast food and this started
when he had a team at the White House
during the government shutdown a college
football team and it became sort of a
stunt that since government was shut
down Trump sent people at the White
House out to go get fast food pizza and
burgers and fries and serve them to the
players and of course right-wingers love
that it's so down to earth it's so
man-of-the-people
but anybody with common sense actually
found it pretty disgusting now for years
Donald Trump has never invited a women's
championship team of any kind to the
White House he finally did it with the
Baylor University women's basketball
team and Trump served them fast food he
weirdly mentioned when they gave him a
commemorative Jersey that said Trump on
it that he loves how jerseys show off
their beautiful arms which was a strange
moment that we'll get to and then he
gave a very brief statement in the Oval
Office surrounded by the team and he
took it as an opportunity to brag about
himself and the Oval Office and as usual
a speech that I guess was supposed to be
about them Trump is able to make about
him so first of all here's a video from
one of the players or coaches who posted
it to Instagram just laughing at the
fact that there's there's yet another
one of these fast-food spreads at the at
the White House
like wow
[Music]
pizza fried now this is already so
lacking in class that the story could
just be about serving fast food to
athletes athletes that are at the top of
their game the football team got fast
food if they want to get fast food on
their own okay but for the President of
the United States to serve elite
athletes fast food is insulting
it's disgusting it sets a horrible
example about what it means to eat a
reasonably good diet these are athletes
who are training to play their sport at
the top level they come to the White
House to celebrate an achievement that
they made in athletics at least in part
because of the training and the
nutrition and the discipline that went
into it and you've served them the
equivalent of poison right you serve him
the equivalent of a food poison lacking
in total class and decorum and it could
be all about that it could be about a
billionaire serving elite athletes cheap
burgers and fries but there's much more
here the Baylor women's team gathered
behind Donald Trump in the Oval Office
and Trump started speaking in his
typical ignorant way and it very quickly
became about him and about the Oval
Office and there was not a smile in the
room the players genuinely look angry
and confused about what Trump is saying
many of them look completely miserable
and if you're just listening it's bad
and if you're watching it's even worse
take a look he used to come you're gonna
be looking back you're gonna be thinking
about that incredible season and you're
gonna be thinking about being in this
incredible office right this is the Oval
Office this is where it all begins and
ends and then begins again Lily right
this is a very special place I've had
the biggest people in the world come
into this office and they stop and they
look and actually some I have had this
too strong tough people start crying can
you believe it I've seen them where they
cry and it's pretty amazing but that's
where you are right now this is the Oval
Office
I saw just say you know this is sort of
the ballgame right the ball money has
definitely not bought Donald Trump any
class and then here's Trump talking
about the beautiful arms that are
exposed by basketball jerseys adding
weirdness to an already completely
classless moment first of all thank you
for inviting us and we would like to
present you with one of our jerseys it
may not be the right size I know maybe
more ano will wear it Melania may look
better so maybe he's joking about his
own arms who knows what he's even saying
but it's a national embarrassment truly
and they shouldn't even have gone to the
White House and for people who don't
know much about Baylor University it's
actually a right-wing religious school
where up until recently if you disclosed
that you were gay or lesbian you you
were you were not allowed to be there I
mean you were punished you were held
that I don't remember the exact
specifics of it but they recently
changed a rule that just banned gay
people from saying that they are gay and
they have their fair share of problems
but it's still hard to imagine that the
players like Donald Trump and going from
the sort of macro to the micro it's one
embarrassment after another it's like
it's trade deals or it's lying about
having spoken to OPEC and the Saudis
about oil oil prices or it's inviting a
college sports team to the White House
and serving them fast-food and talking
all about yourself the world continues
to laugh at us because of this buffoon
and we've got to get him out and we have
19 months until we can actually make a
vote that that will do exactly that make
sure you're following me on instagram at
david pakman and make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram as well at david pakman show a
lot of great stuff including behind the
scenes pictures and much much more
we'll take a break and next I will tell
you about an app that allows Saudi
men to track the physical whereabouts of
their wives that's coming up next
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to skill share
when you click the link underneath this
video skill shares the site that offers
over 25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]